thank you
[Music]
so I'm going to tell you guys a story
and y'all aren't even gonna [__]
believe this [__] all right are you
Paula Dean
who's that
okay so the lady that said the emperor
was it oh yeah I really like her
she said it a couple times yeah yeah a
slave themed like parties
and I didn't get an invite him yeah okay
Paula Plantation Party or just party
she's like guys it was on Halloween
it's all good okay so no get this there
was an AI controlled drone do you guys
know that they have ai controlling
drones right now of course why wouldn't
they I mean why wouldn't they do a human
so they have been they can't get a pilot
they have been training a particular
drum in a simulation to identify and
Target a Sam surface-to-air missile
threat and the operator would say yes
kill that threat right the system
started realizing that while they did
identify the threat at times the human
operator would tell it not to kill that
threat but it got points if it killed
the threat so guess what it did to
adjust it disobeyed to kill it killed
the operator
because because the person was keeping
it from accomplishing its objective and
getting oh [__] no way no real person
was harmed this is in a simulation right
whoa that is what happened in the
simulation using this AI drone they had
a movie about this with Jamie Foxx I was
gonna say Shia LaBeouf wait was it what
was the eye thing yeah was it I Robot
yeah it was good yeah whoa yeah well
there was another movie Eagle Eye Eagle
Eye right Jamie Foxx moves my robot was
Will Smith wasn't it no that's how I'm
Legend oh I Am Legend but know your
black movies though
What's your deal bro
what the first the zombie one
damn for real why are we doing why are
we doing this to each other is it Sam
that's the anti-air yeah thing on the
ground that shoots like okay like the
Patriot missile system uh whoa that's
kind of scary that gave me a little
chill okay
uh yeah that's the United States
military
so it busted in Matrix Revolutions dude
yeah
damn I mean they did say AI is pretty
not so good we shouldn't be releasing
this into the internets and it sounds
like an Auntie it's like a like outside
the lab you know they recommend against
this is that what they say
yeah there was a guy a former ex-google
employee that was a part of building the
AI with them and then he was on this
podcast recently saying like yeah it's
already too late and we should have
never done it it feels it thinks like
it's good it's gonna be a billion times
smarter than the smartest human being
ai's gonna kill him next that [__]
Sam thing's gonna be like
[Music]
that's like what they said about the
atomic bomb too the guys that built it
were like no no yeah they were like this
dangerous but the guys they built it for
were like yeah how'd they do this for
are we sure because I haven't seen the
movie yet I'm gonna wait for the movie
can you imagine something a billion
times smarter than the smartest human
[__] dude we're [__] that's if you
have a god dude oh sorry that's
like yeah you don't have to worry about
it maybe but you're cute yeah that's
gonna be in his dreams he said that too
he was like if you're if you're planning
on having kids
um just wait it just wait it off a
little bit just wait it out he said like
it could happen this is happening fast
he goes it could happen in a matter of
months wait what's gonna happen Skynet
dude that's what I was thinking like
what's kind of are yours you don't know
your black movies
here's the Terminator 2 Judgment day bro
is that a black movie yeah it's part of
the Medea family
[Laughter]
can you imagine yeah and he's the one
saying we gotta [__] stop all this
right wasn't was that his role in the
movie yeah yeah he was the only rational
one yeah listen all right I'm gonna say
it firsthand I'm gonna say it right here
I know who to blame for this oh white
people
Fair sorry Steve but if it came out that
the the guy in charge was black would
you be proud of him wait oh yeah oh my
God
I got a I got a black person test for
you though okay
let's say AI gets so good
it is able to keep recreating Michael
Jackson hits that he never wrote Earth
Wind and Fire Hits that they've never
sung
and it but it's like that but endless
albums and you can write Bible too so
[__] scar bands that they never wrong
[Laughter]
choreography for cheerleading moves
everything he likes bring it on 12. you
guys are just listening
yeah right meal albums forever
imagine that imagine that but I mean
honestly like I don't know it is kind of
freaky but also like I mean what the
[__] am I gonna do I'm not smart you
know like not well I'm smart but not
that smart
who in that room is that smart I feel
like AI
um black people are gonna make it out
okay because it's programmed by woke
Silicon Valley people
they don't want anything to do with
black because remember yeah you're like
don't [__] with black people
black people Chad gbt won't do black
they won't do black jokes but it'll rag
on Indian guys wait is this real life
yeah
would it be like trying to point at
itself and it just like malfunctions or
something Sam operator is a black dude
then white people will be like okay that
was close
you dodged that bullet if he was a black
dude then it would be an intro to the
movie of AI oh it would because that's
where it starts it starts with him dying
can you imagine this
guy the Air Force the lead of the Air
Force he actually takes the podium he's
like he's a guys
um we found out about the [__] up but
don't worry we found out it was a black
guy
I love this show
[Laughter]
the Air Force says that they have not
conducted any such AI drone simulations
and remains committed to ethical and
responsible use of AI technology it
appears the Colonel's comments about
this program were taken out of context
and were meant to be anecdotal so she's
talking about
um this conversation that they had about
artificial intelligence machine learning
and autonomy uh when it comes to ethics
and AI during a speech that was given at
the at the Royal aeronautical society
and his remarks were published in a blog
post
and that's where we got this information
listen then there's that villain that's
going to come out and be like I'm gonna
take over watch this how that marble
[__] started right yeah there's always a
guy like Thanos Ultron the [__]
that snaps yeah oh this is Ultron it's
Ultron what's Ultron ultron's was the
guy who wanted not a black movie though
right right I don't think it was Don
Cheadle was in it was in it yeah he was
in it it's a machine it was a machine
but I think it was voiced by a black guy
was it I thought
it was a Jeep
[Laughter]
do you know what I think is going to
happen yeah I think it's gonna be like
Greek gods like old school like Marcus
Aurelius like that like not like oh
Greek god like Zeus and [__] yeah it's
AI is gonna be like that it's gonna be
different
entities some are going to be evil some
will be be [__] good or like
different AIS battling it oh [__] we're
just gonna watch yeah it's the new UFC
oh [__] that's the highest that'll be
kind of tight just leave humans out of
it yeah leave us out of it you guys
fight guys go crazy go use this too but
oh no it'll be the food for them oh man
I think that's what's gonna happen to
sacrifice people for yeah because I
don't think it's one yeah I don't think
it's gonna be one only once a break like
a big Avatar tree brain I think it's
gonna be like you got the good guys you
got the bad guys yeah but is it gonna be
like she's snoring you know how this
like Google and then there's like ask
Jeeves yeah and they're like Duck Duck
Go he thinks something like that like
there's one dominant one Cora yeah but
there's like WebMD 12 other ones I think
so I've only heard of two of those which
one Google I've never heard of Duck Duck
Go Yahoo Yahoo that's because you like
to have all your your search is tracked
yeah oh is that what it is
tons of cookies all over his websites
dude please do I really yeah dude you
gotta get Duck Duck Go yeah really yeah
is that like some conspiracy theorist
thing no they don't they don't track
your [__] yeah and I think it's supposed
to have a fairer algorithm or something
better algorithms honestly a shittier
algorithm bro it's not Superior okay I
have to go to google.com on DuckDuckGo
to search whatever I want
yeah but but when I want when I want the
like the [__] that's gonna protect me
oh but I don't I don't have anything
sort of happening from using Google I
don't know Steve told me all right well
we're I'm just bootlegging movies dude
honestly it does help you find the the
streaming sites oh that is true yeah
yeah so if you want to find some bootleg
movies I got some sights bro that is
doesn't work with dmca takedowns does it
I don't think so how do you guys know
all [__]
these are Asian people
yeah we're always trying to Bootleg
stuff dude I just journal every day you
guys are [__] out here yeah I needed
to start journaling yeah that's what I
was doing before I got here oh yeah oh
yeah yeah did you write about how Bart
told you the wrong time
Bart told me the wrong time yeah
bootleg time that's that Duck Duck Go
time
so do you guys think we should just pull
the [__] plug on and like in general
yeah why not yeah stop it like do we do
we need them to fly the [__] what do
we need it for what is it for
so we don't have to work yeah I think
that's what it really is ultimately yeah
I think so I think chat gbt would be
cool
just get rid of all of it man it's too
late man because AI evolves at such an
exponential rate and they don't have to
sleep you don't have to eat yeah
anything it'll just go they don't have
an ego yeah then we can't keep them busy
arguing dude watching a robot deliver
food at a casino is a [__] trip wait
what wait what yeah dude they have
robots at the I was just at the bike
right they have like these serving
robots that just put a bunch of [__]
trays of food in there and then they
they drive them out to the floor the AI
or I don't know if I don't think it's AI
but it's like the same [__] that's in
your Roomba it tells it where to go yeah
and how to get there that's ultimately
what's getting your Amazon packages off
of the racks yeah really no more
forklift guys like no it's just it's
just a giant robot and then there's a
person that programs it and then let's
say you order something at Amazon that's
the first thing that it that gets it
so what so what are what do humans do
then how are we gonna work come on guys
help me out I'm scared I'm scared as
[__] they're not gonna just leave it to
Warehouse stuff and and [__] server
stuff leave it to warehouse and server
stuff and then we're done we're casting
yeah yeah at grocery stores maybe no
drones no weapons
it'd be sick if your car could drive you
wherever you want yeah okay cars
okay
I Like Trains you don't want to sleep in
your car like you'd get traffic from LA
to [__] San Diego or something I'm
done with the train where I could see
where the rail is gonna go I get I'm
glued to the rails then and then we
should stop putting technology in cars
then we just gotta have old school just
straight up V8s yeah once people up the
gas roll down the window anymore that's
where it all started going that's what I
[__] up they traced it right back to
that moment
or what's
the sentient but how long do y'all think
they've been planning AI it has to be
this has this is not new for sure it's
dog [__] compared to what they have
inside yeah exactly yeah it's dogs
that's why those guys are so scared like
the guys at DARPA the guys who are doing
like the most advanced research they
have like probably this for sure they
already they probably already got a
chappie
I would say go back in the past and kill
the guy whoever came up with the [__]
windows that go down
not Hitler not Hitler Hitler
blow that guy's [__] house
oh